hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
high-definition video and welcome to the
first in a video series that will
premiere once a month that will
basically discuss whether you agree or
disagree so for this first episode we're
going to keep it relatively simple and
what I have to talk about with you guys
today is a TweetDeck feature request for
those of you who don't know TweetDeck is
a very popular twitter client for those
of you tweeters out there who don't want
to go to the actual twitter.com to post
a message I can also get notifications
for their replies and direct messages
etc the one thing about tweet deck that
I don't like is the actual notification
sound itself now some of you may
actually like it but I do know a couple
of people who actually stopped using
tweet deck because of that annoying
notification sound and I was actually
one of those people who switched to
Seesmic for Windows just to get away
from it for a while now tooth tech would
be happy to know that I came back to
their soft ward because of a few missing
features and other twitter clients but
I've been constantly looking for a way
since then to change the notification
sound into E deck so this is the closest
that I got pardon the background I
actually went into the program files for
tweet deck now there are a lot of things
that can go wrong when you go into the
Program Files of a program and change
things that have been designated to do
certain things I figured it was it was
worth the shot and if it didn't work I
would just go ahead and uninstall and
reinstall tweet deck so I ducked revues
Program Files and I was eventually able
to find that sound which is called ping
deep in the Program Files of tweet deck
I wasn't found my own different
notification sound from destroyed
Twitter one of those many Twitter
clients I reverted to while avoiding the
sound and dragged it right into tweet
deck unfortunately replacing it with a
different sound even though it was named
ping as well also broke tweet deck so
the act of digging into the program
follows a tweet deck and finding the
notification sound and replacing it with
your own notification sound downloaded
from the internet turns out to be
completely useless and you'll have to
reinstall tweet deck for this reason the
topic of today's episode of do you agree
or disagree
is heck does tweetdeck need a way to
integrate its own changing notification
sounds in my opinion yes even if all
this in the Program Files is successful
the average user isn't going to want to
do all that to change that but yet again
the average user does want to be able to
customize their notification sound so go
ahead and leave a comment down below
what Twitter client do you use and if
you use TweetDeck
do you like the notification sound or do
you like the notification sound over the
Twitter client that you use now I'm
interested to see your responses maybe
I'll switch clients again anyway thanks
for watching this episode and I'm
looking forward to your comments again
thanks for watching guys peace